[Music]  we ask for protection over our school  when we pray that we will be kept from  harm throughout the night you see Dad no  get him inside quick you're a most  unwelcome visitor and we do not propose  to entertain you you'll find them easily  amused you won't be here long enough for  that don't you end up in this place are  you so interested in me look at my ear  strength I'm just trying to give them  what they need to survive in these times  if you could have anything in the world  what would it be  the pain taken far away from me come  with me  he seems to be a sensitive person does  he  it seems the enemy it's not what we  believe I hope you like apple pie is  that my recipe it is I need rags  I need chloroform go to the smokehouse  get the saw now  bring me the anatomy book  can I get you anything  give me the key you know I can't roll  Oh wearing it on to be faithful [ __ ]  [Music]  girls we all need to help quickly he's  losing blood I pray that the